we do have a david pakman show subreddit
the subreddit is moderated the subreddit
is well-managed enough that you will not
be trolled into oblivion if that's your
hesitation to participate in the
discussion you can find that at david
pakman.com slash reddit and a few
interesting discussions i wanted to talk
about today the first of which is
someone pointing out that i may have
made a grammatical faux pas the other
day when i said that they are a democrat
someone asking is it grammatically
correct to say they are a democrat and
i'm actually not sure like if i'm
talking about an individual person do i
say they are democrats is oh so that
doesn't make sense unless you're doing
that singular they write the
gender-neutral term yeah but that's not
I mean certainly with Bernie that's not
what I was trying to do I think he's
made his gender identity very very clear
to us so is it is it correct to say they
are a Democrat that someone can't run as
a Democrat unless they they are I don't
know what the grammatical correctness of
it is but I do that I had clarity and
nobody misunderstood but I genuinely am
unsure so if there's any grammar nazis
in the audience maybe you could explain
it some if you made a mistake I think we
can give you a pass you're speaking so
many words per day right right and also
English is my second language which is
also something I like to have as a
crutch to go back to also from the david
pakman show subreddit someone noticing
that interestingly quote both Pakman and
ben shapiro agreed on almost everything
today pointing out by saying that on i
think it was the monday or tuesday show
both oh now they said Pakman and dave
but i think they mean pakman and ben
pakman and been agreed on almost
everything the g-seven the tariffs and
the north korea summit i do think that
this speaks volumes to what is going to
come from the summit and how terribly
idiotic these tariffs are you know there
are a couple people who emailed in and I
said David you're a conservative now you
have the same positions as ben shapiro
on a few issues and i actually disagree
i think that what's going on is that the
Trump doctrine to the extent that it's a
coherent doctrine is so wacky and so
nonsensical that anybody who can even
reasonably assess what's taking place on
this plane
it would realize that the tariffs make
no sense
and Trump at the g7 was an embarrassment
and that the Singapore summit was going
to be a farce I don't think it's about
ben shapiro coming to the left or i left
us going to the right i think it's how
much can two people who aren't
disconnected from the real world see
events and say oh you know what this
this is the one way to interpret it
yeah and politics aren't purely on a
spectrum right there are overlaps and it
can get messy do you ever get people who
tell you that they listen to you on the
left and ben shapiro on the right yes
get you know an understanding from both
sides about particular issues i hear
from people who say that i hear from
people who say they listen to me on the
left and dave rubin on the right which
is interesting because i didn't think he
was on the writer or something like that
he's classically liberal and etc stuff
like that inserted he ideas yeah also an
interesting discussion from the david
pakman show subreddit Hanlan's razor the
other day i said something along the
lines of don't attribute to malice that
which you can attribute to stupidity or
ignorance and I was sort of paraphrasing
and Joseph Rawls posted that it's
actually a phrase called hanlin's razor
attributed to Robert Hanlon and that it
is never a tribute to malice that which
is adequately explained by stupidity
that is the phrase I was looking for
earlier in the week I'll have to start
using that excuse for my hiccups because
I'll take stupidity over malice any day
like people write in and they say Pat is
actually trying to torpedo the show when
he does X Y or Z and then I'm like no no
it's not a liver that it's hanlin's
razor don't worry about it okay and
lastly from the David Pakman show
subreddit David going to ask you a sport
related question as I know you like
soccer what do you make of Argentina's
chances at the World Cup starting next
week I believe that Argentina I've read
a number of different analyses of the
World Cup contenders this year and a lot
of them have Argentina sort of fourth
meaning they'd make it to the semi
finals and lose and then presumably lose
the third-place game right like that's
how you end up worth in the World Cup I
think that that's probably right Germany
and Brazil have excellent teams this
year Spain I think is the one that's
talked about that's bandied about as
third best and I I will be
watching I will be sippy I will be
supporting Argentina but I am not
confident that we are going to be taking
home the title not to mention Leo Messi
chokes and finals we know that so yeah
that's also not good let's see if Messi
can make the penalty kick this time yeah
you may have a chance though right
penalty kick though I mean I know he's
mad what it was there was a free kick
that he had a great opportunity on at
the end of the finals last World Cup but
I don't did he I think maybe he did miss
a penalty again now I don't remember
yeah okay
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash re d di t